so Mitchell with a steel this kid is
relentless and speaking of relentless
Collins runs back and throws it out they
both look good
Martin driven away from the screen the
one to to the cup and there is Collins
with a left hand to slap it into the
bleachers short Illya so beside arms and
a head to Schrute or work in the far
edge farts laughs right to left rejected
by Jack Collins Z outside a little just
lay the seventh under go to work 751 to
play this game thumb drives passes to
use this dirt gets in college though up
so you can get back in a turnover one of
the worst things that can happen right
there live ball turnover 12 left to PG
threading his way through traffic met
with resistance counties is there to
block the shot good screen from Davis
Connaughton into the lane
take it away by a build later wolof path
Oh give me that
then columns are the final spikes
identified in front like CJ go
underneath CJ makes a play up higher
with his arms but his body goes
underneath and let your big man let him
do cleanup duty Napier in Connaughton
and Collins and Evan Turner there's
columns with our injection as a facial
they got him at the laundry man don't
you know it
convenience stores you get cash advance
anywhere there's great Allen she wanted
away by Collins later with the putback
Gert the angle push it up so you chops
bumps off swanigan Collins akin
metal-oxide 25 3-1
in the first quarter have been trying to
make their way back Zach Collins with
the block at about Jim right here off
basketball he stays with the play packs
the ball without fouling let the one
trigger pull up easy trying to get some
minutes and Terry Stotts his rotation
lets you get some minutes in the GE yes
we almost have a scenario now we're all
30 teams have a G League affiliate
correct
Martin inside clock by Collins great rim
protection by Collins their offense had
not been a shot up left open and that's
what you want guys playing in a summer
league to do Zack Collins with the block
on the way Zach calling sporting that
mask Collins very feisty he got a two of
the foots on yesterday I like the sweet
kids left because most of them can't use
of that pencil typically
[Applause]
Deepika burns quickly Colin slapped it
out
Bay with a transition out of here notice
that and made sure to make that a focal
point to give a Ken
[Music]
trusting that jumper last play to me was
a big confidence builder rivers off to
squeeze there's AK against Swannanoa off
the window keep it at play for your
teammate Evan Turner the other way
101 agreed 1500 runs the baseline set
comes off looking a score
Stauskas College Turner on the deck
right now Collins reject Simmons
offering an imperial edict from Dan Tony
was less taking into the lane where they
can stop us well that's right Nick mr.
Justin Kearney transition of three off
the back
feels it flies down the floor
[Applause]
we blocked from snack plate hotel the
ball is released and then go up high
just to step up here he goes again
pass thrown away Bradley the other way
tracking at College don't lock it CJ
will advance it today Mia it's the left
hand up to the ball point guard play
from Damien Lily let's go down to
Brooklyn where they huddle up
[Applause]
[Music]
he said keep it talking Zach pounds out
of the weed snips that barrel over
plates column steals the pasture load up
the floor into the lake Collins gets a
right back Hannah swats it away the day
advances into Turner breaks away to the
cocoon running right-handed champ your
first the first pick in the draft free
wheel of shoot threes it's gonna be even
more chaotic as now oh that was spectra
behind us columns in the back floor got
Lee on the screen strings up Turner back
to Noah for the jam
dude bothered by Colin's back come the
Blazers swanigan on the bush of Boyd's
passing why let her do his back to hit
ahead quickly as tomorrow's jinx and
drives Collins tracks and blocks the
shot back come the Blazers they have an
advantage turn around and Bob from Evan
Turner breaking down the house
this is what I was saying homecourt
could be the difference this team brings
their a game who they have championship
contenders coming in so does the crowd
support fires run that floor at gore and
a nice to live in reaching set Jackson
into the lane rip up by Collins it comes
free to learn all the rebuked by Zack
does a look at that block from Zack just
smothers this ball was deflected and it
comes off the window
leaking out a Gazala train my comments
who makes the play block the shot
Stauskas the other way who feel sick
after the block from Zack has been a
crucial aspect to the start of this game
so far the line he's met by Collins
slaps it off to window recovered by
Turner two percent from the three-point
line as he did but he hasn't missed a
shot mr. Boies Chris dug that the rim
Levine comes the other way
Collins denies that Turner comes up with
it here comes Seth chopping and steps
across midcourt errific baskets and
those are against them hard as nails
Collins at the summit for the rejection
Trent a standstill triple
Jynx come the other way play four on
four pallets rejection shot fires
Leonard flux at three it deemed down the
floor but Bogdanovich was down there
near it Thompson drives gets it rejected
by Collins
Thompson
we had draymond Green under the basket
[Applause]
big time 25 college what I love most
about 13 consecutive points many of
those coming at the free-throw line for
the Blazers because of the technicals
and the flagrant go to credit then off
the Ibaka screen oh that is blocked
nice block my bank balance here Seth
Curry got it keep an eye on this just
said strong move and then Collins coming
right over
feisty possession from curry the cutter
is McDermott denied by Colin McDermott
three defenders common cancer throws it
away
here's Evans in transition euro
Stephanie no Bolton that's a clean
rejection by Colin down the other end
bata a couple over the last few games
it's good to see him knocking down
another one and then he gets back on the
other end and he denies cabaret or the
board
1:43 left of
caldwell-pope has got the green light
bozo sub in for me the green hornet
right off the zach screen so zach is
open for the sack not owns a triple
Longhorn Caruso on the run blocked by
columns at fast retreat shrewder on the
drive gives it up Noel black - Ken
collies has two blocks getting all the
way to the basket yeah he's going early
- that was poked away by yolk it's in
transition Morris gives it up pardon Oh
Zach Collins met will Barden at the rim
look at this hustle by Collins gets
turned around there doesn't stop on the
play backup point guard Monta Morris he
spends little bit out of control to the
one get on the places a chance to tie or
take the lead they got their backup
point guard trying to guard him in the
block and II see Collins he's been
covering up that rim all night long he
was told he'd be coming off the bench in
place of Cragen
get it all party this is a Soviet block
nice block by Collins he came across so
he has the ability to do that right away
he wouldn't have an easy basket now this
is a great block something that he
worked on all summer with his trailer no
cats trying to flood in cancer plugs
right by Collins great weak side hill
that he came from the other side of the
lane to get there and Lillard caught up
and turns it over
Harris on the break deck did
but I heard a whistle yes there was
she'd whitehead thanks take right there
they go strong for the block and then
they get what they get to push off yet
draymond Green Chuck what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content